Transcription: Clémentine Puech
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à tous.
Je m’appelle Lisa Ferrer et ce soir,
je suis là pour vous parler jeux vidéo
et pour vous parler emploi.
Et surtout, je suis là pour essayer
de vous convaincre
qu’il existe bel et bien
un lien entre les deux.
Comme on va parler de recherche d'emploi
ce soir, je me suis dit que finalement,
le meilleur moyen de me présenter à vous,
c’était de vous amener mon CV.
Un peu éclectique.
J’ai commencé bibliothécaire.
Aujourd’hui,
je suis dirigeante d’une start-up.
C’est quand même un beau
grand écart professionnel.
Et puis niveau jeux vidéo, c’est
vraiment, totalement n’importe quoi.
J’ai la bonne ou la mauvaise habitude
de jouer à à peu près tout ce
qui me passe sous la main.
Dans la même journée, je suis capable
de passer un petit peu de temps
à faire vivre des Sims,
aller faire un tour sur Mass Effect et
combattre des créatures improbables,
et puis attraper des Pokémon.
Je joue sur console, je joue
sur PC, je joue sur mobile.
Bref, on peut dire que
je ne suis pas discriminante.
Il y a deux choses dont je suis
particulièrement fière dans mon parcours.
La première, c'est qu'il y a deux ans,
j'ai fait ce grand saut dans l'inconnu,
vers l’entrepreneuriat,
et j’y ai trouvé un espace
d’épanouissement incroyable.
La deuxième, c’est un exploit
qui n’est pas à la portée de tous.
Moi, j'ai complété mon Pokédex deux fois.
(Applaudissements)
Merci !
Une première fois sur Pokémon Jaune.
Game Boy Color à l'époque.
Et puis une deuxième fois
sur Pokémon Argent.
Comme on dit « jamais deux sans trois »,
je continue à m’entraîner
sur Pokémon Arceus
en espérant boucler la boucle.
Il y a un point commun
entre ces expériences,
entre l’entrepreneuriat et mon Pokédex.
Il n’est peut-être pas évident
au premier abord, mais dans les deux cas,
j’ai eu besoin de persévérance,
certains diraient d’obstination parfois.
Ça m’a amenée une bonne dose
d’apprentissage et je me suis dit :
« Finalement pourquoi ne pas faire
voisiner les deux sur mon CV ? »
Ça vous paraît absurde ?
Ça vous paraît peut-être même ridicule ?
Le jeu vidéo, c’est un truc d’ado.
Ce n’est même pas très bon pour les ados.
Le jeu vidéo, ça rend bête,
ça rend méchant.
Ce n’est pas bon pour la concentration.
Est-ce que vous en êtes bien sûr ?
Les neurosciences
et la psychologie cognitive
se sont intéressées ces dernières années
aux jeux vidéo,
et notamment aux effets qu’avait
le jeu vidéo sur notre cerveau.
Et les conclusions qu’ils en ont tirées
sont plutôt à contre-courant
de l’image qu’on en a
dans les médias traditionnels.
Les jeux vidéo ont un effet positif
sur nos performances
et permettent d’améliorer
des compétences cognitives.
L’attention, la concentration -
oui oui, la concentration -
la capacité à passer efficacement
d’une tâche à l’autre.
Tout ça, c’est des compétences que
le jeu vidéo permet de développer.
Et puis le jeu vidéo, ça ne rend pas
spécialement violent.
C’est même plutôt une source de
stabilité émotionnelle, voire, attention,
de bien-être pour les joueurs.
Quand on joue aux jeux vidéo, on peut
explorer une part de sa personnalité
avec laquelle on n’est pas toujours
à l’aise dans la vie réelle.
On peut laisser libre cours
à des sentiments parfois violents.
Au point que même des psychothérapeutes et
des psychologues s’en servent aujourd’hui
comme un outil thérapeutique,
un moyen d’échanger avec leurs patients
dans un espace sécurisant
où ils se sentent bien.
Vous allez me dire : « OK.
Pas besoin d'avoir honte du fait de jouer.
De là à passer ma pratique de jeux vidéo
de la case loisirs
à la case compétences de mon CV », je ne
vous sens pas encore 100% convaincus.
Et pourtant, le jeu vidéo a tout
à voir avec l'apprentissage.
Finalement, le but d’un jeu,
qu’est-ce que c’est ?
C’est de vous amener sur un chemin,
de vous faire progresser
pour que vous puissiez faire face à des
challenges de plus en plus complexes.
En fait, c’est un peu comme l’école.
C’est même mieux que l’école
parce que le jeu vidéo, il vous donne
envie de passer du temps dessus.
Si votre prof de maths ou d’histoire
avait été aussi bon
que les développeurs de Fortnite
pour vous passionner pour sa matière,
vous n’auriez peut-être pas la même
orientation professionnelle aujourd’hui.
Tout le sel d’un jeu vidéo, c’est
d’arriver à bien doser la difficulté.
C’est de vous promettre des récompenses
qui ne soient pas trop faciles à obtenir,
pour pas que vous vous ennuyez,
mais qui ne soient pas non plus
trop difficiles, sinon vous abandonnez.
Et ça, pourquoi c’est important
quand on apprend ?
Parce que dans le cerveau,
les circuits de la récompense
sont directement liés
à la production de dopamine.
C’est cette substance chimique
qui est l’ingrédient principal
quand on parle de plasticité cérébrale.
Et en fait, la plasticité cérébrale,
c’est la capacité qu’a le cerveau
à se modifier quand on apprend.
Est-ce que vous savez quels sont
les jeux les plus efficaces pour ça ?
Je vous spoile tout de suite.
Ce n’est pas l’entraînement
cérébral du Dr Kawashima -
je vois qu’il y a quelques connaisseurs -
et ce n’est pas non plus Adibou.
Les meilleurs jeux vidéo pour développer
ses compétences cognitives,
c’est pourtant les jeux vidéo
les plus haïs dans l’opinion publique.
Call of Duty.
Fortnite.
Doom.
Ce sont des « first person shooter »,
des jeux d’action et de tir
à la première personne.
Et pourquoi est-ce qu’ils sont aussi
efficaces pour développer
le contrôle de l’impulsivité,
la concentration ou l’attention ?
Parce qu'ils sont exigeants.
Parce qu'ils en attendent
beaucoup de vous.
Et parce qu’ils savent très bien doser
leur mécanique de récompense.
Vous connaissez tous Minecraft.
C’est carrément devenu un espace
pédagogique aujourd’hui,
utilisé par des enseignants
du monde entier,
parce qu’on a découvert que des enfants
qui jouaient régulièrement à Minecraft
développaient des compétences
en résolution de problèmes complexes.
Final Fantasy.
C'est un peu plus pour les connaisseurs.
Final Fantasy XIV, c’est ce
qu’on appelle un MMORPG,
cette espèce d’acronyme hyper compliqué
pour dire que plein de gens
vont se retrouver, en ligne,
pour jouer à un jeu d’aventure en équipe.
On a interrogé 118 joueurs
et on leur a demandé
de raconter leurs expériences en jeu.
On a analysé leurs discours
et un petit logiciel en a extrait
un certain nombre de compétences.
Vous savez ce qui en est ressorti ?
L'entraide, le sens du collectif.
L’empathie, la capacité à gérer
des groupes importants
ayant des compétences variées.
Est-ce que vous commencez à voir
le lien avec l’emploi ?
On a parlé d’empathie.
On a parlé de
résolution de problèmes complexes.
On a parlé d’attention, de perception.
Est-ce que vous savez comment on appelle
ces compétences dans le monde du travail ?
On appelle ça des soft skills,
ces fameuses compétences transverses
qui ne sont pas propres
à un métier en particulier,
mais qu’on va retrouver dans
l’ensemble du champ professionnel.
Ces « compétences douces »
pour les francophiles,
en fait, on peut les opposer
aux compétences techniques.
Ce sont des compétences qui vont
vous servir, quel que soit votre métier,
quel que soit votre secteur d’activité,
et quel que soit
votre niveau de responsabilité.
On en parle de plus en plus
parce que les transformations
du monde du travail s’accélèrent.
En 1987, une compétence technique avait
une durée de vie moyenne de 30 ans.
Aujourd’hui, cette durée de vie
est passée à cinq ans.
Et ce n'est pas grave.
Des métiers qui se transforment,
il y en a toujours eu.
Que je sache, personne n’est choqué
qu’il n’y ait plus d’allumeurs
de réverbères dans nos rues.
Par contre, on a besoin des soft skills
pour faire face à ces transformations.
Les entreprises l’ont d’ailleurs
bien compris :
aujourd’hui, sept des dix compétences
les plus recherchées par les entreprises,
ce sont des soft skills.
Et les recruteurs nous disent
que les soft skills, c’est parfois
plus important que le diplôme
quand on cherche la bonne personne.
Alors la prochaine fois
que vous chercherez le petit plus
à mettre dans votre CV,
vous n’oublierez pas
votre jeu vidéo préféré.
Merci et bonne soirée à tous.
(Applaudissements)